i made a video claiming that the iphone
14 pro would get a brand new hill-shaped
cutout but unfortunately it looks like i
was actually wrong now the reason i was
so sure is because of ross young he
currently has a 100 accuracy rating for
apple leaks now he just came out with a
leak that the 14 pro models will have
both a pill shaped cutout and the extra
circular cutout at the same time we've
already seen quite a few updated renders
online but it actually have two very
good reasons for the selfie cam being on
the left instead of within the pill
shaped cutout on the right i had renders
by shylesh update the previous render to
add in the extra hole on the left side
this would absolutely be the path of
least resistance for apple since the
selfie cam is already on the left side
on the iphone 13. one of the features
many believe apple might add back in is
the battery percentage indicator and i
believe that's actually much more likely
to happen if the extra hole punch is on
the left side instead